foreign
how can I heal after finding out my
husband has been keeping secrets for me
throughout our entire 28-year marriage
but the most disturbing to me is that he
had showed to these random online
people's photos of me sexualizing me
[Music]
hey what's going on this is John with
the Dr John Maloney show the greatest
mental health and marriage podcast
so glad that you're with us hope your
family's well hope you're well and uh
man we are going to get into the deep
end of the pool today if you want to be
on this show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask a-s-k
don't forget don't forget if you are in
need of supplements we have a great
partnership with Thorne t-h-o-r-n-e the
best supplements on the planet in my
opinion
um it's what I've used my family's use
for years and years and years and we
have partnered together to give you guys
25 off everything and um it's it's
really a it's a gift from us to you uh
25 off everything in the store go to
thorn.com you just the letter slash
deloni we'll put that in the show notes
Thorne t-h-o-r-n-e slash you thorn.com
deloney check it out and get all the
stuff that you need fantastic
um all right let's go to Rebecca in
Medford Oregon what's up Medford uh not
Medford what's up Rebecca how we doing
hi Dr John thank you for taking my call
of course really big fan I really
appreciate it thank you so much I'm
grateful for you what's up
um I'm just wondering
um I found out some very shocking things
10 months ago I found it out all in one
day
um my question is how can I heal after
finding out my husband has been keeping
secrets for me throughout our entire
28-year marriage what kind of Secrets
[Music]
um but I had a a weird feeling
um and I checked his computer
and what I found out was completely
overwhelming
um he had reached out to an
ex-girlfriend
um two years prior
um nothing came of it but he had reached
out
um I found out he had a porn addiction
um lots and lots of porn it seemed to
have
it escalated it looked like into some
Kinks I had no idea
that he was into he was reaching out to
couples
um
he was in chat rooms the way that he was
speaking to other people was definitely
not the person I knew were very close
we've been best friends for so long we
just you know we're very close we have
each other's backs I knew him inside and
out and I feel like he knows me except I
have never once lied to him the way he
was speaking to these people
um was crass graphic
but the most disturbing to me is that he
had showed
to these random online people photos of
me
sexualizing me describing my
measurements
um and a desire of me to be with another
man in front of him
they weren't nude photos of me but they
were racy photos you know just shorts um
and like a low-cut tank top that you
know I just would never ever in a
million years think that he would share
that with someone
um and all these things I found out
were were so shocking and I just found
out more and more stuff as I as I read
through I started crying
um I felt like I had been kicked in the
stomach and that everything I knew about
him
was it just switched in a moment's time
um I I I just I had no idea he felt this
way or that he was even capable of doing
something like this
so this was 10 months ago
um yeah tell me about the last 10 months
how's that going
um well I I kicked him out we have a a
trailer so I kicked him out
um to get some space I was Furious uh I
couldn't stand to even look at him how
did he take that did he say I understand
no it T gaslit me and made excuse is
until
as when I approached him I gave him a
chance to be honest on his own and he
was not and it wasn't until I presented
him with black and you know there in
black and white what I read and he could
not deny it anymore and then he became
no he left willingly
um he let me kick and scream he took it
and then he was just he wrote me a
letter after letter after letter while
he was gone just he's in deep shame
I'm extremely remorseful crying
um it's been a rough 10 months very up
and down
and he I mean he went so far as he made
a list of everything he was going to do
to get better
and has followed through with most of it
um he may you know he became very
transparent
um he put
um you know locks on anything porn
related
um he just quit overnight it seemed just
overnight and all of that I appreciate
he's been trying very very hard he did
promise to go to counseling and get us
in marriage counseling if I would agree
and that has not happened
um we've actually been for 10 months
he's been fighting with the insurance
company and not getting a response yeah
I don't care I don't care about that
um yeah uh so how can I help you so it's
like just though the whole world blew up
um it blew up I didn't know how we would
go on right
um I I felt trapped sure
I felt absolutely trapped overwhelmed
and we had just moved out of state and I
thought I would I told him I would have
never made this move with you if I had
known this was going on the hardest part
for me now yeah how can I how can I help
you yeah from just my point of view is
that I feel I don't trust myself I don't
trust him I don't trust any other men so
I feel helpless in that
I feel disoriented
um and the anger like I do I do really
well we do we do fine and then all of a
sudden the anger will pop up and it
keeps popping up and I know I want to
heal from this I want to get better
it it's gonna take a long time
[Music]
11 months four days three hours
um so good I got my calendar yeah it'll
it'll just clean right up right there
um yeah okay couple of things I it's
very very rare
that this doesn't happen
that
he hasn't come fully clean
so that's number one yep okay yep
um number two
it's very rare that this happens that
somebody says I was completely blown
away caught off guard that remember that
movie The Sixth Sense with Bruce Willis
and remember the end of that movie and
you're like oh no and they actually do a
really amazing job of showing you all
the places where you missed it
yes and it's easy to look back on your
life and go oh no oh no right and that's
right that sense of
I think I knew this all along or parts
of this or not all of it but oh my gosh
this makes sense and then I remember
this conversation I remember this
question and then that's that feeling
you get which is most people don't
realize that when somebody's cheating on
you
are Unfaithful in any number of ways oh
yeah the most disorienting thing is you
don't trust yourself anymore like man
how did I miss all of this right yeah
um
I also think that this is a little
unique situation and here's why
um
it feels like you don't know this guy
and you can't trust this guy and
everything about him is a lie that's not
true
he is the guy that sat with you and I'm
just gonna make up some stuff I don't
know if any of this is true but he is
the guy that sat with you when your mom
got sick he was the guy that showed up
on Christmas morning like those things
happened and those are real and you
can't throw all of that out that
happened
okay okay
um and it's real easy to be like none of
this is real none of this is true that's
that's a defense mechanism it is the
harder part is dealing with the Paradox
of you sat with me and held my hand
while my dad passed away and then you
went home and got on our computer
and that that's a harder thing to deal
with than just swinging that thing my
husband's perfect my husband's the devil
it's always in the middle always in the
middle okay
here's where I think this is a little
bit unique
um and I hope I say this the right way
in a way that comes across that makes
sense
he clearly violated your trust and he
violated um he kept secrets from you
okay yeah when it comes to things I'm
interested in or it comes into a fantasy
world
um that's not uncommon okay it's
heartbreaking and it makes people sad
but it's not uncommon
okay where he crossed a line for me
is he took pictures of you and put them
out to the world
he brought you into a situation
that
um in a way that is for me personally is
above and beyond a normal guy got
started looking at pornography and kind
of got sucked on a rabbit hole and ended
up you know in some chat rooms and just
it becomes Dungeons and Dragons a
pornographic Dungeons and Dragons right
it's a fantasy world so super separate
from The Real World okay that is crazy
as it sounds that that doesn't bother me
that is I mean it bothers me in the
clearly hurting people it's not weird or
crazy okay yeah what's weird and crazy
is taking pictures of your wife and
putting them on the Internet and saying
hey any any Seekers here's her
measurements that to me is such another
layer of a violation here that
um I I I'd have a hard time coming back
from that to be honest with you because
yeah he's uh he dragged you into
something that you don't even know
you're being dragged into
no idea right and so I want to validate
your I want this to work but I can't
seem to make it
right like you're hurt and violation is
very very very real above and beyond
what I would call and I hate to use this
word it's just the world I'm in a normal
um
pornography addiction or a normal
um uh violation like someone's someone
is you know spending time erotic time in
a fantasy world this is above and beyond
and so
the question you have to ask yourself is
are you playing house
are you playing Mary just on your terms
meaning you kicked him out but I still
go to dinner with him we've still been
intimate we're still friends we're still
hanging out all the time
but then I just get raged out and what
you're doing is you're
you're trying to heal a wound but you
keep pulling the Band-Aid off
yeah
is that fair yes yes okay absolutely
you've got and it and I hate to bring
his feelings into this but they are a
part of it because y'all been married a
long time and his feelings are a part of
you whether you want them to be or not
um it's can be cruel too as it could be
it could be well it's a form of
punishment I'm gonna punish you through
this right yeah and that doesn't help
anybody do anything that's that's a
that's a waste of energy and time what
you have to decide is what do I need
right now and I'm telling you just as
your friend if you need I need to cut
off contact with you for a season
feel fully empowered and no it is Hell
on the other side of that
yeah it's lonely it's sad it's
heartbreaking and that doesn't mean it's
the wrong thing
okay okay and yeah if everybody's
telling you you just leave them you
forget this guy's a bum whoever and you
say this is my husband and we're gonna
figure this out I said till death do us
part come with me I'm here
um that's gonna be a bumpy ride too and
so maybe the best gift I could give you
is there is no smooth ride out of this
the hard part is nobody knows
no that's right I have a I have a
therapist but I just needed to talk to
you to even say it out loud because
nobody knows they think he's perfect
and so you've heard me say this from the
great David Kessler grief demands a
witness
and what's hot what your what you're
experiencing right now that anger that
Rage that's grief
yeah that is we set this sucker up dude
and you blew it up
yeah right it feels like grief it is
that's exactly what it is you are
mourning the death of what was
and now what you get to choose is what
is going to be and if we if you choose
for what is going to be with him great
y'all gonna have to work really hard
and you're gonna have to get a new
architect to help you draw a new
building and you're gonna have to get
new contractors to help you build
something totally new because what you
had is over it's gone it is yeah and if
you choose I'm moving into a duplex um I
don't want another big building that's
another Avenue for you as well
um but I haven't seen that very
successful
without some space
and I have never seen somebody do this
successfully by themselves about without
telling people out loud
they're going to be
um
you know I mean you can probably guess
my fear in that is that I don't want
people to judge my husband
um
yeah
isolated I feel so isolated right
and you are continuing to prop up the
image of this perfect little family that
you had
you have to let that go because it's not
real
yeah you're right you're right and maybe
the first step is calling a close friend
and letting them letting her know I'm
about to blow your mind
they they will fall down in shock it I
mean I I can you know I
they will go through a fraction of what
I went through when I found out because
I why are you protecting them why are
you protecting him
I'll tell you why you've been protecting
him your whole marriage
yeah oh I have yeah I know you're all
married you've been protecting him at
some point Rebecca you have to decide
that you're worth being well and you're
worth being whole
even if that means what what you the
fantasy land you've kept duct tape
together for 20 or 30 years is no more
yes
or would they say what if they say
things back that actually hurt me they
will they will say stupid things like
well what did you do is it such a big
deal like you'll get all that stuff
right and really quickly you will be
able to determine how close these
friends actually are
but let me tell you the word like the
word that we're dancing around here that
I hate more than anything is
vulnerability
you only way forward to heal
is to vulnerability literally means to
roll over and expose your belly so that
another animal can come kill you
and hoping that they choose not to
and that's what it feels like right oh
that's fear yeah oh my gosh so let me be
very clear your friends could roast you
they could destroy you
they can
yeah but if you don't find people to
talk to this will you will be the
casualty here
yeah it's so isolating I feel disorder I
feel disoriented it is and when you
start saying these things out loud and
seeing the shock on their face you're
going to get a new perspective of what
you're experiencing so before the day is
over your homework assignment is to call
two friends
and invite them over
and tell them everything
all of it
everything even the stuff you left out
which I guarantee you left stuff out of
this call
and maybe open up to your friends and
say I ain't gonna I'm gonna need help
practicing not protecting him
anymore
I'm gonna need help wading through all
this grief all this shame all this I
should have said something a long long
time ago I've had these feelings in my
guts for years and I just ignored them
ah
you're gonna need help practicing
trusting Rebecca again
[Music]
in many ways it's gonna feel like you're
going to rehab and learning how to walk
[Music]
so sorry I'm so sorry
I'll be here with you every step of the
way call anytime email anytime and I'd
love to have you back on the show and we
can figure this thing out together as we
go but you gotta have two people that
you called today invite them over in
person tonight and have that
conversation
that is uncomfortable as it's gonna be
it's where the healing will begin we'll
be right back
[Music]
all right people all of us procrastinate
about something maybe you've been
ignoring your check engine light or
maybe you've been putting off plans to
read more whatever it is good sleep is
not something to put off sleep is the
foundation for your mental and physical
health and like your check engine light
your old mattress won't just fix itself
so don't procrastinate here quality
sleep starts with a great mattress like
dream cloud with their one year in-home
trial there's no excuse to keep tossing
and turning on your old mattress that
keeps getting more uncomfortable by the
night it's time to invest in good sleep
and dream cloud is the only luxury brand
that gives you a full year to try out
your new mattress a full year stop
procrastinating I know you'll love your
dream club right away just like my
family does right now dream cloud is
offering my listeners 25 off your order
plus 50 in additional savings and why
not
599 dollars in accessories with promo
code John deloney that's pillows luxury
sheets and a mattress protector so go on
dreamcloudsleep.com and use promo code
John deloney today and also probably
don't ignore that check engine light for
very much longer
all right we are back uh I'm super
jazzed about this call uh no pun
intended because uh John's calling from
New Orleans but this is a follow-up call
to a call we had is about seven or eight
months ago
is that right August August okay
um
a call that was Haunting and
heartbreaking
um and we're gonna link to the original
call in the show notes
um fantastic but then John's calling
with an update what's up man
hey Dr John how you doing today I'm
doing great man how are you
uh we are we're surviving uh we're doing
good all things considered very cool man
all right so
um I've heard you've got an update call
so walk us through well I'm gonna do a
quick recap and you tell me if I've got
it or not so
um your daughter got sick it looked like
it was E coli and in short fashion her
system started shutting down and the
folks at the hospital pulled you in the
side room that I've been in too many
times and with families and they said
hey you've got some really hard
decisions to make
and
you guys decided hey we want to transfer
out of this hospital and go get a second
opinion and they fought you on it but
eventually they let you do it and they
took you to another hospital and they
were like hey don't give up on this
little girl yet
um we think she's gonna be okay
um is that is that a good summary
summary
yeah
um it's a pretty accurate there okay um
correct and we we transferred um you
know to the Children's Hospital here in
New Orleans and our whole world
um got flipped back upside down again
but in a in a better way and um
Scarlett started recovering and I think
when we spoke uh last time I was on like
day 38 of what ended up being a 75-day
hospitals day and
um
Against All Odds
um this little girl who we were told
would never walk never talk
um you know have very limited life uh
capabilities if if she survived
legitimately walked out the front door
of the hospital yeah dude that's
incredible man
carrying balloons everyone clapping and
cheering for it was
um
she made a lot of really really smart
people
um looked um
as kids usually do right
oh my gosh
um I mean we're still living in it we're
living in a different uh in a different
uh reality now yeah but um so what
limitations does she have now
I'm sorry say that again what
limitations does she have now or she is
she up and Adam running around
uh she's upping at it running around
um she has some uh hyper uh flexation of
her left knee and some uh she postures
with her left arm she's on a feeding
tube
um you know we still have we still have
some stuff she goes to
um about 45 different appointments a
month between physical therapy
occupational therapy speech feeding and
seeing all the specialists
um
so she's a very busy little two-year-old
are you seeing some progress
um oh yeah uh she's jumping off the
couch and doing all the stuff the
two-year-old's supposed to do and and
scaring us and all the the normal ways
now good I hope she scares you all to
death not as bad as she did the first
time but the regular the regular way
right good good good correct well dude
you like as I told you last time as the
dad of a little girl man like you
you've lifted my spirits and I'm really
grateful that you called back is uh is
there anything I can help you with like
what's going on in the world now
oh yeah
um you know we had a fantastic support
system while we were in the hospital and
we got home and and you know everyone
went back to their
um to their normal lives and routines
and you know my wife and I we found
ourselves uh you know living in a
different in a different uh reality that
most people don't understand
and you know now that we're six seven
months out of being out of the hospital
we're trying to grieve and process and
and move forward
um in our new reality
and what it sounds like we've you know
we've been seeing some counselors and
what's been described is that me and my
wife we've landed in two different
places in our grief and the handling of
our new reality
so I'm looking for advice on how we can
both work on ourselves which has been
painfully hard to do so that we can get
back to the same place all while
managing those 45 appointments
um all the feeding issues running a
household and equally as important
giving proper care and attention to
um her big sister oh man yeah that's a
that's a big one I'm gonna give you a
really unconventional probably not PC
answer is that okay
go for it I'm almost positive that none
of your therapists are going to give you
this answer
and it's something I've just been over
the last couple years traveling the
country talking to people about trauma
and about with coming back from some of
these things
and
here's a couple of really important
things number one you gotta get rid of
the just get back to language
there is no just get back to
what was is completely gone
and so often we spend so much energy
trying to get back to the way things
were that
um and you're experiencing this and I'm
trying to read between the lines here
but these kind of situations often break
up couples simply because they grieve
differently and one person is like how
can you be moving on and laughing and
carrying on and the other person is like
how can you stay mired in this and
continue to relive it and relive it am I
on the right page
uh yes okay and eventually somebody says
I've got to go find joy in my life and
eventually somebody says I've got to
find somebody who understands the hell
I'm in and both of them end up you know
a thousand miles apart from each other
and so and even though they may be
sharing the same bed sitting on the same
couch right and so
you have to get rid of any sort of
comparison think of your old self as
your neighbors you got a different life
man there's there's no no benefit to
comparing what was the only thing and
this can actually be fun and exciting in
a way to bring people together is to
decide what are we going to build moving
forward what do we want this to look
like that's number one is we have to
decide we're going to build something
new not just get through the next month
and the next month and the next month
and try to get back to some semblance of
normalcy normal's over the second thing
and this is where people are going to
disagree with me and I don't care I'm
right is
I don't think that married couples after
the first and
maybe a first couple of months of trauma
healing
if a couple is gonna make a go of
creating a new life together the healing
has to be done together
so after the initial here's how I'm
processing this trauma here's how I'm
processing this trauma and this is
bringing up this stuff in my life and
this is bringing up my life a lack of
control and all that great you gotta
process these things alone but the
majority of the work the bulk of the
work has to be done
teaching two people okay I know you feel
like the world's coming to an end every
time you open your eyes it's not
so you have to choose to get up and do
hard things I go for a walk and exercise
and have sex again and watch funny
movies again and you over here who's
just trying to run and be like it's all
going to be great and Pretend This Never
Happened you've got to spend some time
grieving on a regular basis and that
might look like journaling and that
might look like a weekly breakfast where
you say the words I'm really scared
about and you answer right and the goal
is
both people have to do hard things
creating a new tomorrow together
and I think the only way you can do that
in y'all situation is to do couples
counseling with the intent of we're
building something new together we're
letting the old thing go
tell me where I'm telling me how does
that hit you
um it it hits pretty pretty close to
home here okay
um I think that's something that we're
we're maybe just starting to do with the
couple's counseling okay
um you know we're only a couple sessions
in
um and you know I've been seeing
therapists which is a challenge in
season trying to see therapists which is
also a challenge and but getting us
together has been difficult
I would at this point unless there's
some some psychiatric issues meaning one
of y'all's on meds now and one of y'all
seeing a psychiatrist like absent that
I would if I'm in your shoes and again
I'm talking to you now just as a dad a
little girl and a guy who's married
I I would spend the bulk of my energy on
how did me and my wife create something
new together
and not spend all these sessions like
well he's not doing this and she's keeps
doing this that's just not productive
it's just gonna send you on a loop right
and the more you stay on that Loop the
more maybe your optimism and you are
look how bright everything is
serves as the same defense mechanism
that she might have which is this could
happen again this could happen again
this could happen again and you end up
going nowhere right you end up going
nowhere and so getting together and
saying okay we're gonna spin the and
maybe you tell your couple's counselor
here's what our goals are our goals are
to build something completely new
because everything we knew blew up we
almost lost our precious daughter
and now we don't trust the world we walk
in We Are catastrophizing Everything one
of us can't put the news down one of us
can't quit pretending that it's all
going to be Rosy and great I'm tired of
driving and I don't have anyone I can
say those things to you right so how do
we build that relationship together
moving forward
I would be real intentional with your
therapist and if your therapist says
well you know we need to go back to it
may not be the right therapist for you
right now
all right I'm I'm trying to jot notes
because we need to be very intentional
here here's what we'll do I'm going to
send you a raw link to this an unedited
link to this right after the show I'll
just we'll just send it to you okay and
um it'll probably be a little bit
different that Sarah and the editing
team make me sound a lot better after
the show then uh during the show but
that way you can have some of these
notes you can take into the counselor
and I'd also if if your wife is up for
it I think it's worth having this
conversation with her
absolutely and I've I had it with my
wife like uh and I've talked about on
the show like where I told her man like
man I just thought after you got
pregnant like okay nine months and then
I get my wife back my crazy fun wife and
then I realized after Hank was born like
okay maybe nine more months and then
things go back to normal and I didn't I
never realized oh things never go back
to normal everything's different now
everything's different and then we had
Josephine everything's different we had
all these miscarriages everything's
different we got a new job everything's
different so the the adventure of life
now is not trying to hold on to what was
but it's creating a rhythm where we can
create something new at the drop of a
hat because that's how the world works
all right and I feel like I feel like
we're getting there you know you are
we're either a extremely used to our new
reality or it's
um you know we've we've made a lot of
progress with her and we're starting to
get to the point where I think that we
can we're in a place where we might be
able to try to build something new like
you're saying that's awesome can I tell
you this
it's okay to be really annoyed by all
the appointments
it's a lot it can be it's okay to be
really pissed off at all those bills
that start coming in
and it can be really mad when your
daughter's jumping off a couch and it
kind of pulls the feeding tube and then
she cries and you've told her and you
feel guilty for yelling at a kid that
almost died like all that's okay
like you're not a bad dad
for being pissed off you're not a bad
dad for your wife coming home so
exhausted because she went to seven
appointments this today and you're
trying to work a full-time job and be a
dad to your other kid
and you're just exhausted and you're
just mad at everybody oh that's okay man
thank you okay and it's okay for her too
and here's a simple thing you can do
with the other daughter and then I'll
let you go
um it's as simple as do you drive her to
school how does she get to school
uh we live close enough we walk okay
um it may be worth having a special day
once a week where you just drive her and
you get some cheap cheesy breakfast
somewhere
and she has special I mean it can be as
little as 30 to 45 minutes a week a very
special check-in time with Dad and if
Mom's available
um she can rotate but just a here's my
special moment and another thing I would
do is I would put a small spiral
notebook or take her out somewhere and
let her buy a real fancy notebook and
you put it on her bed and you write
notes back and forth to one or other and
when she gets done writing a note she
puts it on your bed and then you read it
at night and then you write back to her
but it will be your secret private thing
that nobody else gets to touch nobody
else gets to mess with that sister can't
ruin and screw everything up
um it's just a special Channel between
dad and mom and their their daughter and
and it sounds very minute and very small
these are big big things to a little six
and seven year old
that sounds amazing and yeah she's six
years old so yeah dude she's writing it
she's writing it
um another thing is to always let her
feel a part of things whenever possible
so say things like
um what are some things we could do to
help your sister today or to your your
this baby of yours here at the house
um and giving some ownership and
responsibility age appropriate of course
can really add to like a young kid can
walk really tall and I've loved seeing
I've worked with special needs kids for
my whole career and I love seeing their
brothers and sisters because a lot of
them are gangsters they're there
gangsters man because they're used to
hey you you're gonna give access to my
to my brother you're gonna let my sister
have the appropriate resources and they
become real great Advocates and it's a
fine line because you don't want them
doing adult work you don't want them
responsible for their brother and sister
that's a burden they can't carry but
when they have a little bit of of
support and a little bit of of hey
you're in this too this is your brother
and sister Anne man some kids will take
that and run with it and it's a great
gift it's a great gift
um but find those little moments where
you can look that little girl six year
old in the eye and say Oh Daddy still
sees you too
daddy sees you and every day I thank God
that I get to be your dad
oh man it's awesome that gets me uh
that's one of my favorite things in the
world all right brother John hey call
anytime um keep us updated how things on
how things are going and I'd love to
hear about how you're uh marriage
counseling works out when you come in
with some notes to your therapist and
say hey here's what we want to do here's
where we want to go thank you so much
for the call my brother I'm so grateful
your daughter's doing awesome we'll be
right back
hey good folks John deloney here I I
feel like I fell through a glitch in The
Matrix this is my job I get to have this
show do this show walk alongside each
one of you as a career this is what I do
and I have a blast doing it and me and
the team were so thankful for all of you
for being a part of our show whether
you're one of the original 17 or you're
one of the millions that's come since
then we are so grateful for you and we
want to put together the best possible
show that we can so if you're one of The
Originals or if you're brand new we want
your feedback tell us what you love
about the show what you hate about the
show would you like to see more of would
you like to hear more of and what you
want us to never do again you can email
us at askjohn ramsesolutions.com that's
askjohn ramseysolutions.com with your
feedback thank you for being such an
important part of the show rock on
all right we're back let's go to Sarah
in Louisville Kentucky what's up Sarah
hey how are you good one time I called
it Louisville and I did not end well for
you so don't do that I'm out of the
hospital now and it's Louisville
that's right that's right what's up
um so my question is when do you push
through hard conversations with a new
friend and when do you just let that
friendship go
just let It Go Don't hold back anymore
uh that's the great Elsa saying
um okay give me more contacts
so I had a neighbor who wants to be
friends and she said she doesn't have
very many friends so I recently started
including her in my friend group but
that has caused um some issues for
example I invited her to girls night and
um
she ended up talking so much that a
couple people suggested I either talk to
her about making sure the conversation's
more Equitable or not inviting her
anymore
um I'm a little afraid of how that
conversation would go if I did talk to
her especially because she does already
seem to be aware that she dominates
conversation
and as far as not inviting her goes I've
been that girl without friends before
and I really don't want to just abandon
someone who's lonely yeah
yeah
um
oh man making friends as an adult is the
worst it's
worst I know when you were in
they were playing kickball and there was
either the Nerds that loved kickball or
the kids that were like I hate kickball
and they had their Hello Kitty backpack
and their little uh Trapper Keepers and
they would just be ironic and like but
you just like found your friends and now
there's neighbors and it's like oh
you're weird you're weird
um how do you know that she knows that
she dominates conversations
because she'll say stuff like sorry I'm
talking so much or she'll say sorry I
talked so much tonight I'm just really
excited or things like that so she's
she's very aware that she's talking a
lot but you so desperately want to be
like well then how about you stop I was
just
your responsibility
as just a human on planet Earth to take
in all of the cases of loneliness in the
world and make them yours to solve okay
so I want you to I want to relieve you
of that I also think there are some
low-fi ways to solve some of this
potentially okay okay so I'm gonna send
you a whole bunch of questions for
humans cards and okay here's what my my
wife said she loves these things and
here's why
I talk too much a lot I talk way too
much and I got opinions on everything
especially when we're just hanging out
just with a couple friends and whatever
and
she said when you're going through these
cards everybody gets a turn so somebody
has to stop talking
and it lets other people tell their
story and
a good friend thing is when somebody
else is telling a story and the person
who has to always be heard
starts talking someone go hey hold on
let her finish and they're little things
like that that aren't rude or not you
being a jerk or anything like that but
they're just subtle quiet like hold on
hold on I want to hear this story
is a oh yeah okay yeah you see what I'm
saying and it doesn't have to be
dramatic big but it's just a quick like
hold on I want to hear what she has to
say about this I do that in
administrative meetings sometimes in
meetings there's two or three people
that talk all the time and there's three
or four people who are really quiet who
have lots of great ideas but they don't
say anything I'll stop back hold on hold
on I've already heard from you I want to
hear from so and so and I'm just pretty
direct about it and I don't think
anybody thinks it's mean or ugly or rude
um it's just I want other voices to be
heard and sometimes just
doing a little bit of quarterbacking can
someone can slowly get the message and
learn does that make sense
yeah wouldn't that be more for like if
she was interrupting somebody though
it's not so much that she's interrupting
people who are already talking it's that
you know anything that comes up she has
a better story for it do you know what I
mean it's not like a oh no stop with
that let's hear from you know what I
mean yes and better story people are
really tough they're really tough like
oh yeah well one time I like all right
all right oh yeah yeah
that means hard I mean I I don't know
there's an easy way through it I do
think with some if I'm in your situation
I would probably attempt some modeling
and if
um
and it may be that there's certain
friends like I've got certain friend
groups that I hang out with there's I go
watch the fights with a group of guys
and I play music with a different group
of guys
yeah just different they're just
different folks who do different things
I thought about that too
um just she said that she said that she
the girls nights
she was like this
and she knows I do it regularly
so if she doesn't get invited again yeah
um again yeah she's an adult functions
she's an adult and she has her she is in
control of her feelings
you are allowed to have events at your
house with the people that you choose to
have events with
okay choose guilt over resentment every
time
so you wouldn't even try to talk to her
about it no I would I totally would okay
I would as you approach that like I said
I would I would do something like hey
we're gonna play a game a direct game or
like I'm gonna send you the the girls
night cards and the questions for humans
friends I'm gonna send those to you and
you can pass them out and be all right
everybody's gonna answer one and they're
gonna go around the room
we're gonna go around the room
the hard part is we did something very
similar to that I had everybody write
down two things about themselves
gonna go around the room and um so some
people got some time to talk just
it still ended up like a one up and then
a one-up you know
I think I think that that's your job is
to to play quarterback and to model
something new which is after the first
one up and the second one up when she
starts to one-up somebody else go hold
on hold on we're gonna go to the next
card
all right you see what I'm saying yeah
yeah I I that's that's what I would do
if I have I mean uh
yeah that's just hard I wish there was
any shoe wavy and it's just not an easy
way it's just tough
um
I can also see a scenario where this is
very much like the you got a booger in
your nose conversation
and
um like I can't think of a more graceful
honorable thing than when someone like
pulls me aside it's like hey dude you
got a booger in your nose
I got so kind and lovely even though
we're both gonna be weird now
like because I want to be like why are
you looking up my nose weirdo and B
thank God somebody told me right and so
it may be like hey we're gonna grab
coffee and like hey it's gonna be weird
and awkward and hard and you're my
friend now and so I just want to tell
you
um
like everybody who tells a story you
always have a one-up story and a better
story and it's just making it make it
hard
okay and that might be an awkward
conversation but it can't be any more
Awkward than what you're feeling right
now at least you'd have some resolution
right yeah yeah that's true at least and
she might tell you you know what I you
go to hell I hate you and I'm gonna
bring your house down when you're when
you're on vacation she might say that
and she might be like okay thank you so
much finally somebody told me right
yeah
yeah I did wonder if just nobody had had
the courage to have that conversation
and just kind of opted out instead and
that's why she doesn't have many friends
and it becomes self-reinforcing right
she feels people pulling away and so
then she tries to tell more stories to
keep them engaged and then they start to
pull away more until she gets louder and
faster and be like oh yeah well one time
I and it's just a symptom of wanting to
be a part of what's going on and yeah
somebody doesn't feel whole enough it
doesn't feel worthy enough that their
presence is enough like the fact that
you showed up and brought dip and or
beers or whatever you brought that's not
enough you have to you're only loved
because you got another story to tell
and it's communicating no no I'm really
glad you're here and you're making it
hard to for us to want you to stay here
this is tough okay yeah and the people
in my life who've had that conversation
with me on a number of issues I think so
so highly of them
my buddy Trevor when I was in college
like when me and the person who's my
wife now when we broke up I was like she
said this and this and he was like dude
you're an idiot
and I was like what do you mean and he
said it way more colorful than that but
he was right he called me out and it
literally changed I didn't see it from
my perspective when he saw like dude I'm
your body I'm your roommate and this is
I see how you treat people dude it was
eye-opening for me I've had bosses Dr
Thompson did this for me Mike Gibson did
this for me I've had people all through
my life pull me aside Dave Ramsey's done
that for me like hey here's a thing I
see in you and it can be really great
and it can also be really isolating and
so every time somebody's done that it's
hard to hear it really is but what a
gift man it's such a blessing when
somebody has the courage to do that so
um
again in a Publix Forum like with a
bunch of people around that's not the
place but a private quiet conversation
might be the place I would do it after
getting some cards and being real direct
and having some some time during this
time like during the event where you're
like oh hold on a second I'm gonna let
so and so talk I want to let Ben talk I
want to let Kelly talk I don't let
Christian talk like I I want to let them
I want to hear what they have to say and
give somebody a picture of what it looks
like to just sit through it
um and not have to comment on everything
and then after that if it keeps up and
keeps up and keeps up maybe it's worth a
worth a conversation
choose guilt over resentment
Jews guilt over resentment every single
time every time
you're awesome Sarah best of luck to you
making adult friends is the worst we'll
be right back
[Music]
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right we are back
um hey don't forget it it means a lot to
me it means a lot to the team and to
folks who have never heard of us before
please hit the Subscribe button whether
you're on Apple or whether you're on
Spotify hit the Subscribe button YouTube
hit the Subscribe button
um and leave your five star reviews
wherever you can it's a real gift spread
these episodes out to folks who um you
think would be impacted positively or
negatively by them that'd be awesome
nothing says I love you like you should
probably listen to this episode about
what a terrible husband you are that
would be fantastic uh as we wrap up
today's show
finally a band that I love Queens of the
Stone Age Kelly hates this man she said
actually right before that's why I
picked them because I love them you jerk
whatever she doesn't have this tattoo
though she's got all the other ones
um
the Lost Art of Keeping a Secret goes
like this well I've got a secret I
cannot say blame modern movement to give
it away
you've got something that I understand
hold it in tightly call on command leap
of faith do you doubt cut you in I just
cut you out whatever you do don't tell
anyone
this is kind of how Kelly lives her life
whatever you do
don't tell anyone
it's kind of the opposite of this whole
message of this entire show
[Music]
way to go Kelly hope you're happy with
yourself
I love you America stay in school don't
do drugs we'll see you soon
[Music]